the next award will be presented by one
of Hollywood's most versatile couples
he is an author comedian composer actor
musician and poet Steve Adler Steve
Allen Steve Allen the Adlai Stevenson a
show business and his favorite bookmark
Jayne meadows I guess he's still writing
his play on
thank you very much Bob well Jim I guess
there's no award tonight for the best
handling of cars in the parking lot so
you might as well go right all right and
now that all five nominated nominated
songs have been presented the green
beads of summer the second time around
never on Sunday facts of life and far
away part of town now it is our
privilege to announce the winner the
envelope please
I might as well do the honors game all
right dear if you're tuning it right
welcome to work I've got a secret
what never on Sunday
accepting for manos hadjidakis brow JEP
I guess he won't be here till Sunday
what is these well I'll stand here and
write a song myself one of the optional
plans
is that mr. Manas hadjidakis in the
house it's hard to tell I guess anytime
how are you like to say a few words
about Las Vegas
Musab I just got word he's on a bus
coming from Yugoslavia I hope it's not a
greyhound but listen how do we get off
of here I think this is the moment I've
been waiting
this is a very modest fellow that didn't
make the trip but I'm sure if you
deliver this back to the committee I'm
sure they'll take care thank you very
much thank you Strickland